The Ten Commandments maintain an extraordinary hold on our imaginations
even though many of them can sound – in
the context of our own times – really rather
peculiar, with injunctions not to
covet a neighbour’s livestock or to make sure one doesn't carve images
of god-like figures in the rocks.
The Commandments
were responses to the specific needs of a small nomadic
community, wandering the Sinai peninsula with
goats and sheep around
1,200 BC. Our needs have, predictably,
changed a bit since then.
But a place for rules remains: because we're still
horribly prone to violence, cruelty and self-righteousness
and need regularly to be reminded of how to
live peacefully and well with ourselves and
our neighbours.
What would it be like to try to update the commandments for our own times?
Here is a go...
The good person is at all times
highly aware of their flaws and committed
to becoming a better version of themselves.
They are not insulted if people point out
their need for evolution, even when they do this rather clumsily.
A good person believes in ongoing need for moral and phsycological education..
The good person knows that everyone is deeply damaged and a little
mad, starting with (of course) themselves.
They are unfrightened by their own strangeness
and are committed to informing those around
them of it in very good time, and apologising
retrospectively when they have failed to do so.
They understand that part of their duty is
to have a ready answer to the legitimate question,
‘And how are you crazy?’
The good person
is loyal in relationships not because they
think their lover is perfect, but because
they know that everyone is pretty imperfect
and rather hard to live with at close range.
They accept that the only people we can ever
think of as normal or easy are people we don’t
yet know very well.
The good person knows that it is impossible to be wholly understood
by anyone and accepts that things are going
well if one is very lonely in around only
half of the key areas of one’s life.
The good person tries hard never to assume
that other people should know what they are
thinking of or want without them having told them very clearly and kindly. They
try to resist sulking (behaviour that stems
from an incensed belief that others should
know why we are upset without us having  told them)
and are committed to teaching others
about the contents of their minds.
The good person looks at people who are behaving
badly as if they might be small children;
that is with patience, charity and an active
search for mitigating circumstances. Though
our societies stress the insult of being treated
as younger than one is, the good person knows
it is the greatest privilege for anyone to
look beyond the apparently strong yet nasty
adult to the worried, anxious and probably really rather
nice child within.
Confronted with a piece of stupidity or evil which they could never
be guilty of, the good person doesn’t fall
into self-righteousness. They swiftly remember
all the many stupid and evil things they have
at other points, over different things, been
guilty of. They don’t lose sight of how
much they overall stand in need of the charity
and forgiveness of others.
The good person is committed to searching for the funny side
of people who might appear merely desperately
irritating. They look at others like characters
in a comedy rather than a tragedy. They know
that the greatest achievement is to be able
to move from seeing someone as an ‘idiot’
to considering them as that most privileged
of beings: a ‘loveable idiot.’
The good person is a firm believer in restraint
and in not immediately saying certain things
that are on their minds. They hold that being
fully oneself entails a level
of melodrama and rage that one should spare
any human one cares about.
The good person knows that the best protection against impatience
and paranoia is a little gently-worn pessimism.
They budget for disappointment far ahead of
time. They don’t cry constantly only because
they have understood that the whole of existence
is – in many ways – worthy of tears. Their
constant awareness of the possibility of death
and catastrophe makes them especially appreciative
of small things that happen to go well. They
relish flowers, balmy skies and so-called
‘boring days’ when everyone manages to
go to bed relatively content and at peace.